les états-unis utilisent le dollar
utilisez votre monnaie nationale
pour différents types de sanctions
monde des sanctions, eh bien, par exemple, vous êtes ici
vous comprenez ce qui est en jeu, pas parce que
États-Unis mauvais dollars sur je les aime
imposer des sanctions, nous voulons donc qu'elles
se débarrasser de mais non bien sûr la question a
valeur pratique pratique
personnage
mais disons que nous ne pouvons pas le faire
règlements en dollars avec nos partenaires
coopération militaro-technique
vous savez que nous avons des problèmes et que faisons-nous
fais
on passe aux calculs nationaux
devises, nous passons aux règlements dans d'autres
monnaies d'autres pays